how you guys
doing good how are you i
i cannot complain um so i have a lot i
want to ask you guys about
uh with honest thief but um i have an
individual question for each of you
prior to getting started uh for uh kate
i have to ask you um
how many of your costumes in umbrella
academy did you borrow
i actually didn't keep any of them or
borrow any of them
i returned them all graciously to
netflix
um they were most of them involved a
major corset of some kind so they
weren't the most comfortable
but uh yeah those are all archived we
hope to actually do a little
tour with those at some point when the
world opens up again
uh they were fantastic and i will say
that you really should try to get some
even even with the corset okay
just throwing that out there and with
liam i have to ask you um
does it ever get old talking about love
actually
no it doesn't actually strangely enough
no
it's just so nice to um
it was just lovely to be a part of that
film
um you know a movie that starts
i'm just remembering you're immediately
gripped by that film because
you hear hugh grant saying as you see
all these real passengers getting off
airplanes
greeting each other
all the messages before the twin towers
were
murdered were messages of love
and once you hear that that's the
opening of love actually and that still
gets me if i'm flicking channels and
that comes on i have to watch it
not all of it but i have to watch that i
think it's such a
an amazing opening god liam could you
bring it anymore
down geez
sorry about that i'll just say i mean i
think for a lot of people it's a
favorite
uh myself included um jumping into why i
get to talk to you guys today
um you two had some great chemistry in
this
were you guys was this one of these like
a super fun shoot was it a challenging
shoot
how was it behind the scenes we were
in love
[Laughter]
what i'm gonna say
i have to say no it was it was a joy to
work with kate
and i i know that's a cliche but it was
an absolute joy
uh she's a great actress she's funny
she's smart she's very easy on the eye
and we just had a good time
no it's a story about two people
of a certain age finding love maybe for
the first time
certainly for me my character and uh
just
kate just made it so easy also mark
williams made a great kind of easy set
right and um so it was just
oh yeah it was just a blast it feels
like so long ago but it was so
and um you know and the local crew and
everybody was wonderful too outside of
boston and worcester massachusetts it
was we had a
it was that was uh it was cool it was
cold there were some cold
moments but not that cold not i mean you
even you shot the gray my god this was
nothing this was like a
a tropical experience i'm sure compared
to that
i'm swimming
but it's fun yeah one of the things over
the past decade
liam um people have shown again and
again
myself included that they love watching
you punch people in the face
um it's it's really true though i mean
it's been 12 years since taken and and
people love seeing you in action movies
what is there any secret to pulling like
is there something that you figured out
as to why people love
watching you punch people in the face
and kate what's your take on this
well there's a part of me feels like a
kid in a toy shop
to be honest i i do these things
uh these fight scenes i i i get to work
out with these
amazing stunt guys i get to be with my
stunt coordinator mark van slow we've
done
excuse me 24 films together now um
and it's it's like being a kid in a toy
shop we're learning a dance
we rehearse it reverse it person and
of course they don't actually obviously
punch each other in the face but
uh sometimes you'll get very close to it
it's just fun it's fun sure
yeah i had i don't i mean i think
everybody loves to watch
liam be a hero and fight for the
underdog
and um i mean i i've always
loved that but i also for me it was
really fun that's one of the reasons i
wanted to do this it was a really fun
fight scene for me
and i was like oh that i was like that
sounds like a lot of fun other than
this guy uh yeah it was really
it was a it was a lot of fun and mark
was amazing um
mark van slown who liam's talking about
he was the stunt coordinator for the
whole thing and it was incredible and it
is like a dance and it's so precise
and uh and you have everybody else on
the stunt team that just make
made me look good and it was uh that's a
lot of fun though it's a real adrenaline
rush
yeah you that was a really good fight
scene in the um storage
unit place uh you did a very good job um
for my last question for each of you i
know that making any
projects you're always gonna have a dare
to that you'll always remember whether
it be because you effed up
whether it because it was just a great
day when you think back on the making of
this film
like what's a day or two that you will
always remember
you know i'll have to be honest every
day was kind of special
really was i i i just you know
making movies is probably one of the
great joys in life
if you're an actor and uh you know when
you reach a certain age i was 66
i'm 68 now i was 66 when i made that and
i kept
nipping myself in the arms and how lucky
you are
to be doing this acting with this lovely
lady
getting to do fight scenes and it's
but truly steve every day was was kind
of a joy
i remember the first day i was about to
was we were shooting at the house liam
when i was about to make
the entrance on the poor i was waiting
on on the porch
and i thought oh my god here we are i'm
making a movie
i'm with liam i'm like oh my god i'm
about to go into my house
and you do still feel like a kid like
you just feel a little dorky and like
excited like a
kid at christmas a little um uh and
that's a great feeling you know no
matter what age it's like okay
it still feels brand new and uh so i
feel very
very lucky and grateful we had a great
wonder yeah now i'm like oh my gosh can
we go back there
especially now it's very uh makes me
very
wistful on that note i just want to say
congrats on the movie thank you both so
much of your time
for your time and enjoy the rest of the
speed dating
thank you